please welcome back to the show rosie
perez
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you
i wore a pantsuit for you
i am noticing your fashion i am picking
it up the second you walked out i love
this color green monochromatic suits are
trending
yes so you're super on trend oh yes
exactly
that is fashion aspiration at its finest
this is uh christian siriano's oh i love
christian siriano
and i was just staring at his instagram
on oscar night and you were wearing his
gown on the oscars yes yeah he made it
for me i wanted to be in black and he
was like no you're going to do red i go
no i'm going to do
black and he's like doing red and so i
was like you can't tell me what to do he
goes yes i can you're gonna you're gonna
do red and so when i saw the dress i was
like wow
okay
it's so beautiful oh thank you i i told
him that i i wanted to look you know
sexy but i wanted to look grown up sexy
i didn't want to try to compete with the
younger girls because i like being my
age and i mean it's so funny when we
started to say like we did riding in
cars with boys together this beautiful
film that i hold so dear to my heart how
long ago was that what 20 years ago
probably yeah maybe even longer yeah i'm
not kidding and then how long ago was
white man can't jump one of the greatest
films ever made i was so excited
to see that reunion i still say in my
head
almost on a daily basis foods that start
with the letter q
like
i still i don't know why but that is
always in my head it was 30 years
30 years 30 years yeah and it was so
good to see them because i had not seen
woody harrelson and wesley snipes for
maybe seven years because we're still
friends you know but we you know our our
lives you know get busy and everything
like that so when i saw them the first
day it was the day before the uh
event
it was just like old times and we were
just kidding and laughing around and
then the night of the oscars i saw
wesley's outfit which which was
was fabulously ridiculous and um
i said what do you think woody's gonna
wear and he goes he's gonna look like a
hot mess and i said no and then woody
walks in and wesley and i just started
cracking up and woody goes what's the
joke and then wesley said nothing you
just look like an undertaker at the
oscars but you're good
you're good and um yeah because the suit
did not fit him well i'm sorry to say i
love you i love you woody but
i love it i mean that you in that film
boy did you just show everybody how
invaluable the woman is oh it's like you
are the biggest
force in that movie
and that changes things it really does
it's important when somebody is that
dynamic and the film would just fall
apart without them it's like oh you're
so good in that movie you're such a
revelation thank you i'm bugging out
right now why
because we've known each other forever
and it's weird to sit here as two grown
women who are doing their things and
don't get me crying don't do it don't do
it don't do it i'm just so proud of you
i'm so valuable
oh my god
you know
you know what i
mean longevity we're still here that's
right
lucky to have this opportunity
[Music]
you